um
and now i'm playing i am polina
schwallowa
i think she's going to be a gm pretty
soon um
and i think she also won the junior
girls
world championship a couple years ago if
i'm not mistaken
anyway let's try a move i haven't played
so far today which is one c4
and g3 sort of uh
neo catalan line
yeah she goes everybody seems to go for
this line
what should i do
quincy two maybe
b6 usually black or c5 right
it's a bit strange so d4 dc4
transposes into a completely acceptable
line so maybe i'll try and take first i
guess now knight d5
maybe there's just isn't much for white
at all
i don't know to be honest
okay
i'm gonna just try and grab a foothold
in the center
while i can i'm trying to figure out if
d5 is playable after c5
probably isn't d5
ed ed
queen d5 knight h4
queen d7 rook d1 queen c8
knight f5 looks very strong now
looks very strong indeed so earlier when
i said
i don't think it's playable i meant it's
not playable for black obviously
so i'm gonna go for this um
i'm gonna i'm gonna do a podcast later
in norwegian unfortunately about the
super super league
so you'll hear my thoughts then
okay queen d5
looks reasonable
there's some sound
rookie one
uh quincy eight
knight five rookie 8 i guess is the only
only transfer it may not lose
immediately and if it doesn't lose
immediately
it may even be good for black
um but it looks
don't know just looks very very strange
maybe this is just modern chess and i
miss the boat
like you calculate and if it works then
it works
okay let's try
97 rookie 7 don't see any tactics there
yeah i have to play
so we're going to go for something very
very
violent
and if night uh
gh96 i think she probably has to take
though
don't know what else to suggest
i can't say that i necessarily see a win
there
kg7 probably
she's spending a lot of time now so
possibly we will enter
flagsville later on
okay interesting obviously i don't have
time to think but i'm gonna think a
little bit still
takes
okay we'll take
oh queen of five or cafe maybe
yeah now i officially have to speed up
okay we're just gonna
enter hustle mode then
knight knight c6 queen f5 rook d7 is a
threat
and also queen of six okay rook d1
let's go let's go knight a6 looks wrong
i think now she has
too few pieces in defense
i could be wrong
hoping for rook d8
okay now there's mates i probably have
some quicker mate there